We're doing Bollywood today.
(gasp)
Oh my god, he planned that.
That was the coolest thing I've seen.
They're doing a really, really classic technique which is...
What's up guys! We are back with a very exciting episode of VFX artists react.
We're doing Bollywood today, and...
Hey, yo, where did Niko go?
Niko had a baby.
Yeah that's right, he had a baby! A beautiful, little, baby girl.
What are we gonna do without Niko here?
We'll be fine, we'll just do it ourselves. Yeah, we got it.
(Intense Indian music starts playing)
(Action movie sound effects starts playing)
Hey guys, my name's Sam.
I uhhh...
well.. you know me.
Sam, how did you learn to intro like that?
Well, I have a little clip I'd love to share with you.
(Action sound effect) Oh geez!
Baahubali
Baahubali! So this... there's a clip from this movie that went viral on reddit.
These guys all have these sweet shields, they get on this tree, and you're like, why are they on this tree?
And then it immediately becomes apparent!
Whoa, oh, wait, see it gets more complicated than that.
Oh my goodness dude! Look at that. That's how you intro.
That was the coolest thing I've seen.
The transition from spinning to sliding is so sweet.
Everyone does it too?!
Oh my god, that's the last time they ever plant trees.
Those guys didn't make it!
Little 300 action. So many splinters, so many boo-boo's... That's gotta be all CG. That's so cool though.
This is really well made. Really well produced.
That was like 300... on acid
and mushrooms...
...at the same time.
So they get flung, and the premise is that they're holding onto each other, and they curl up into each other to block the arrows.
That's kind of what this whole scene is about. Is a bunch of crazy stuff, no one cares about physics here...
Basically when they're mid-air, that's 100% CG. Once his feet hit the ground it becomes real.
That's a photo scan.
And then it transitions... see right there, see the transition?
From 3D model?
Okay, yeah I do see it.
This shot is a really good example of CG transitions. Generally like, impact points are some of the best
Moments in a shot to transition from something that's fake to something that's real.
It's a really common trick to look out for when watching any visual effects shot.
If you see someone flying and then land on the ground? That transition point is generally
the moment their feet touch. Or anytime there's like a sharp movement.
This shot right here they transition to an element that doesn't have any motion blur.
The whole background has motion blur, but those guys don't.
This is the opposite example, where those are three real plates of people on wire work
but when they pull back to show the fall, they have CG doubles that are doing the fall.
So they don't have a clear transition point. This is a single smooth camera move, It's slow motion, like, there's nowhere to hide that transition.
Oh what the heck?!
And they're still just gliding upwards. There's no acceleration at all, whether negative or positive.
There's a lot going on in this shot. There's a lot. There's a lot going on in these shots.
Like that splinter. The catapult getting splintered into a million pieces.
Oh, look at that guys cheering!
Yeah he's holding it with one hand in pointing at it. This is like a CG dude.
Yeah there's CG people down there.
He's just standing there and he just goes...
So this is again what you're talking about Sam, there's another impact transition from the CG shields to these guys actually jumping.
If you look at the shield. Like, the
Lighting and rendering quality of them? It's really, really close to the live-action version. You, see that?
Yeah it's extremely close.
I would bet that they're still CG. Coz look, see the shields Center?
It freezes while they're still moving. The center middle shield freezes for like four frames while everything else is moving.
It's not actually real yet.
It's still the CG shield, and that's how they're able to move them so fast, coz those would be heavy.
That is smart.
Like I'm willing to bet as the main guy comes running in he's not actually holding the shield.
He's got a tiny shield? Yep, It's a CG shield.
That's the trick!
You just keep people guessing. is it real? or is it not? because sometimes it is and sometimes it isn't.
Keep the illusion going.
That's some good stuff right there!
Oh! This is the Indian terminator right?
Yeah this is Indian terminator. Oh I've seen GIF's of this!
What? He's got magnet hands, he's like Magneto.
Wow
Wow, wow, wow
Wait, that didn't stop him? that didn't stop him? he got t-boned and he's still chill.
Like, look at that?!
This guy is... oh I love this. I love this so much
Wow
Wait a minute...
Oh my god! Through the whole bus!
What does he know that we don't?
Oh!
Ohhh!
Oh my god he planned that!
He planned that, he knew!
I love how they just like, filmed this with real traffic by the way. This is like, they're actually in traffic
They don't close the roads off completely. Are you kidding me?
Is this where he? (gasp)
It's happening
Oh, that was a CG person there. There you go. That person was computer-generated.
Wait, so this guys on the other side?
Oh my god!
Oh that's incredible.
Is this like The Mask? didn't Jim Carrey do this in The Mask?
That sequence is pretty crazy.
A lot of the visual effects is right there to enhance and highlight the extreme wire work and rigging work that's done constantly.
Because every single time you see someone mid-air, you see a car floating for a second,
like 99% of that stuff is being done with like, cranes and rigs and wires.
That's what I love about these scenes, Is the scale.
Like literally it's... there's swinging cars around, with people in the cars with cables.
So a ton of the VFX work has gone into painting those wires, and those cranes, and rigs out. It's an invisible effect.
Which we're doing an episode on by the way, so subscribe if you guys want to check out the invisible effects episode.
So let's break down some of the actual technical things going on in this scene.
His head turning around backwards is a motif in this film.
Generally, every time they're doing it, what they're doing is they're actually doing a green-screen plate of the actual actor turning around.
Right there looks like a green screen plate. Yeah, that's a real face we're looking at right now.
You can see like right over the brow, above the eyes here
The specular highlights are right, there and it looks like a real face
But then we cut away
And then we cut back to him, and now it looks like a plastic face.
It looks CG
It looks CG coz you can actually see a little bit of that feathering
Along the edge of like the top of his head. It's like a soft edge.
Yeah
These are both the same actor here. that's not the same guy.
It's the same actor actually. What? It's all about this inventor who creates a robot with his likeness
They look kind of different enough that I wasn't able to tell it was the same person. same.
And they're doing a really, really classic technique, which is using motion controlled camera rigs.
It's allowing them to replicate the same shot twice.
Basically pull an actor from one footage and put it in the other, while having a moving camera.
You have the the background of both different shots with the person in different spots
Match up exactly. Motion control was invented for Star Wars, because they had to do all these different
passes of like the backgrounds and all the different
Spaceships. And now with computers you can like program it in. You can just do the same move over and over again.
You see in lots of movies. The one I really liked was from the movie Limitless. Oh, but look at that
He's hugging himself. Is that how do they do that? How are they doing that? It's a guy in a suit
That is not the actor and then they're simply doing a head replacement. That's really flawless
That's pretty good for as goofy is like the physics are in in a lot of these action sequences
There's a lot of legit visual effects work that's done really well in this piece.
I feel like clone effects are one of those things that people are always going to keep working on improving
It makes sense though, too
Because like cloning myself was like one of the first effects I ever did. It was literally my first effect ever.
exactly because visual effects artists spend a lot of time alone and when you don't have anyone around you
You need to be the actor in all roles. It's basically the first thing a visual effects artist learns.
Oh shi-
Well, okay, hold up. what? okay, that's awesome. It looks it looks legit.
Aw man, wow just wow
Dude this is like Katamari from hell. Yeah.
dang, dude
This is dude. How imaginative is this?
Yeah, this stuff doesn't look so realistic
It seems ridiculous and it's like, okay, this is crazy
But okay, if you had to film a scene where 50 robot dudes turn into a giant ball and beat everyone up.
Like how do you actually go about planning and executing that sequence? Because the moment they go into the sphere obviously
this is all computer-generated.
Super solid job on the lighting matching the lighting to that CG ball
Then the heads all spin around so they obviously have a really high-resolution photo scan of his head.
There's a million things going on on here
Which are pretty cool
Several different plates of people getting pulled by wires and then they combine them all and then transition to the 3D elements of them forming
Into the sphere. So all the head plates there. It's all legit. Oh my god
We thought those were CG
All the faces are practical. face is the one thing that when you make fake people tend to notice all the other stuff you can
Make fake and really realistic
They actually have a giant wire ball that they used to film these shots, which is exactly how I would do this as well
Too. It's like if I have to do a whole sequence with a giant ball
I need a giant ball there to film and then they're running him through for lighting reference.
So Wren, see this this ball right here that he's holding? What is that ball doing?
So it's literally just reference for the visual effects artist later to figure out what sort of lighting the scene has.
What a sphere shows you really well is the direction of a light and the intensity of that light from that direction.
It's kind of hard just to create that stuff from scratch without knowing what it should look like.
A lot of the robots are CG in this but there's an actual child in this robot costume.
They crammed a kid in there? They crammed a kid in this. Look! See where the head has to be? Yeah.
Oh my god. The unsung hero is that kid.
So we are only scraping the surface here of awesome Bollywood movies.
And if you guys know of anything that we should check out. Cool visual effects? cool action scenes?
Leave them in the comments below, we read everything
What? So look at this, look at that!
Does that look familiar? yeah, that's that's the same sort of hit from Mission Impossible 3!
But that's actually, I would argue that that was a way better hit. Nah dude
Lame. See look how weak that looks compared to- No but they got the gravity right. They got the motion
Correct of his fall. The other one looks better. And also the impact is really good. Yeah he crunches dude. That crunch?
Oh my god, like ouch. Even on a pad or whatever the heck you're hitting, like god dude
You just got like an inch shorter from compressing your spine.
Yeah he folded into that.
There's a little bit of jank involved
like, oh his actual fall is linear there. He kind of like slows down as opposed to accelerating
Him like, hitting it is fine
But then like, the moment he hits he kind of bounces off and slows down a little bit. Yeah
Yeah, they ramp his speed basically post hit. What do you think? which one looks better? Mission Impossible 3? or Singham returns?
Bollywood is, as cheesy as it can be, I think it's amazing
It makes me laugh every time, it's really easy to pull one up and laugh at how ridiculous it is
But ultimately what these guys are doing here. They are first off, completely disregarding physics, reality, all that stuff
They don't just take a normal shot and say "oh we're done with it"
No, they'll do anything they can to make it as intense as possible.
By the way
Like, I just want to point this out. We made these videos called
Tacti-cool reloads. And while it may seem that they are like, anime inspired
We realized when making the second one that they're actually bollywood inspired. It's basically how cool
Can you do this mundane task? Like how cool is your intro? How cool can you light your cigarette?
How cool can you just hey, sit down, you know? offer someone a chair.
Yeah
so if you guys other
Bollywood movies that have cool visual effects or cool stunts or even like,  Chinese cinema. Things that are a little more
unfamiliar to the American audience? Leave them in the comments below. We would love to check out this stuff.
So it's that time where we thank some of the special patrons who help support this channel.
If you didn't know we have a patreon, now you do. Check this out. Big thanks to all of our patrons
starting off with Nick S.
Canadian Goose
Oscar Bunting. Phillip Oxford. Astro GG
Alan Almanza. Warmaster236. NotaCanadian Spy. Mitch Ploenske.
Skeanky Snack. Glitchcube. James Bailey.
And Brian Antoszyk.
And of coarse, like any classic movie where you have thousands of visual effects artists,
We also have all these names who are patrons of us. Thanks, everyone
And of course if you want to support us on patreon
There's a link in the description. Lots of different tiers that you can support us at
It really helps us out. Brings new episodes of this to you every single week. Thanks for watching. See you guys next time.